Now we know that we can refer to
XML resources in the Java code.
But what exactly is the relationship
between the resources and the Java code?
How do they come together as
part of a full app experience?
Let's start at the point when you
click on the JustJava app icon.
It opens up the Main Activity.
Now you don't see anything yet
because it's still being initialized.
Thankfully, a lot of the complexity
involved in initializing the activity is
handled automatically for
you by Android.
The important part that we care about
is that in the Main Activity file,
the onCreate method gets
called automatically.
This is when the activity
is getting created.
There's a bunch of work and
then we have an important line that says
setContentView and then the resource
ID for the layout file.
It's R.layout.activity_main.
This means that the content view of
the activity should be set to the layout
as specified in
the activity main XML file.
This is the method call and
the input parameter is this resource ID.
Once you set the lay out that you're
going to use for the content view,
then the android device can go ahead and
start parsing this XML layout file.
Parsing is like reading this file and
trying to interpret that like
oh this is a linear layout.
Oh this is a text view.
These are the attributes, and so on.
So it's trying to understand
what this file contains.
The Android device starts by
reading at the top of the file.
It recognizes that there's
a linear layout here.
Then it inflates a Java object
to represent that linear layout.
Then it goes to the next line and
sees that we need to add a TextView as a
child to that linear layout, like that.
This is starting to look like
the view hierarchy from lesson two.
What I didn't tell you earlier is
that this is actually a hierarchy
of Java objects.
We're going to be learning more about
Java objects in the coming videos so
it's okay if you don't
fully understand it yet.
When we get to the next line
we see that we need to inflate
a linear layout Java object.
That gets added as a child
to this root LinearLayout.
Then we see a Button element.
So we add that as a child
to the LinearLayout.
So we continue down the file until we've
inflated all the views that we need for
our view hierarchy.
Once we have this view hierarchy of Java
objects, then we can manipulate them and
change them while the app is running.
An object like the TextView here
contains state information.
Like the text, the text color,
the text size.
The object also has methods so
we can call those methods and
change their internal state.
So for example, we can change
the text while the app is running.
Interacting with all these objects is
called object oriented programming.
We will cover this in more
detail in the coming videos.
So to summarize, in the main activity
when we call setContentView to this
layout, then we read this layout and
then inflate a bunch of Java objects.
These Java objects make up
the view hierarchy of the app.
The MainActivity holds on to
this view hierarchy, and then
as you interact with the MainActivity,
it can update these objects.